now we were just talk about the economy
and we can now speak to the man in
charge of the public finances the
Chancellor received sunic thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning mr. scenic and I'm keen of
course to get to the economy but I just
wanted to start on the protests that
we've seen the Prime Minister described
what we saw yesterday as racist
buggery how would you describe it I
would agree with him I think the scenes
we saw yesterday were both shocking and
disgusting this has always been an open
and tolerant country and what we saw
yesterday
was not that and I fully support the
police and taking the action that they
did
it's sad that they had to and I would
urge everyone to remember that at a time
when we're facing a pandemic in this
country to be mindful of that and to act
responsibly the new aspect to our
economics editor ed conway a bit earlier
this week and you said that races and
stings in a way that very few other
things have but the things that might
happen many years ago when I was a kid I
think things that would not happen to me
today I just wonder when you saw the
actions of some not all but some of the
people out yesterday clashing with
police Nazi salutes are you still
confident that some of the things she
might have experienced as a child
wouldn't happen today of course there
will always be a small minority who
maintained prejudice and indeed are
racist but that is not over all the
description I would ascribe to our
country and the point I was making to
add and I'd I'd reiterate is I think
there's been enormous progress that our
country in our society has made if I
think back to the time when my
grandparents first arrived when I was
growing up yes I do think things have
changed enormously for the better
because of how we've all evolved as a
society that doesn't mean a small
minority still hold beliefs that I find
abhorrent and all of us collectively
share that and I think what was
interesting is the country was united in
condemning what they saw yesterday and
that just shows the progress that we've
made I mean I understand if you don't
want to go into details and feel free to
tell me to move to the next question but
you know are there any examples of
racism you've experienced that you'd
like to share it feels at a time many
people are talking about their own
yes I have I mean I I've I've spoken in
the past and the things that stung me
the most actually as when I've been with
my younger siblings that when I was
younger and things that were being said
to me it's one thing when they're
happening to on your own it's difficult
enough but when I had my younger brother
and sister with me at the time I mean it
was particularly upsetting I didn't want
them to have to deal with it I did I
wanted to protect them from it and as I
said you know those things they may just
be words actually but they they sting in
a way that other things don't want
people you know call you lots of names
and lots of different reasons there's
something about that that cuts to your
core but I said that's not something
that has happened to me for a long time
and I think as a society it's not
something that is common and that's
because of how we have as I said evolved
and adaptive as a country we've made
enormous progress and as we've seen
people I can see that people are upset
and they're angry and they won't change
but you know change comes slowly and
real change doesn't come from wanton
destruction or violence that that is
wrong it will always be wrong and our
story as a country isn't finished of
course there's more to do but it's also
a point to remember that this is a
welcoming tolerant diverse country where
progress has been made that's something
we should be very proud of and remain
united in condemning what we saw last
night and whenever we see prejudice and
discrimination we should call it out for
what it is which is unacceptable
according to the Sunday Telegraph
ministers are considering plans to
introduce prison sentences up to 10
years for demonstrators who desecrate
war memorials do you support that yeah
it was one of the most distressing
things to see yesterday was that and I
know many people certainly MPs have
raised this issue and the Justice
Secretary will be meeting with all those
MPs I believe this week to discuss these
matters further but that was absolutely
shocking scenes to see yesterday okay
and now I'm keen to talk about the
economy as well because the situation
really is unprecedented genuinely
unprecedented figures out this week
showing out economy shrank by quarter in
March in April that's 18 years of growth
just wiped out in two months now when we
last spoke which feels like a long time
ago back in March and you said that
coronavirus is gonna have an
impact but it will be an impact for a
temporary period of time I mean that now
feels quite optimistic there's been talk
of up to 3.5 million job losses if the
economy's restarted soon we could be
dealing with the fallout of this crisis
for the rest of our lives couldn't we
I'm more optimistic than that but I
think you're right what we've seen
others we saw this week just lay bare
the scale of the economic impact that
this lockdown has had on our economy
over the past few months you know we've
always known that what's gonna happen
but now the numbers are starting to show
that and these aren't just numbers these
are people's lives and we're seeing many
people are losing their jobs and will
lose their jobs as a result of what has
happened that's families without
security that they have come to depend
on that that weighs very heavily on my
shoulders but I think the you know we
have a plan going forward we've put in
place the first step of that plan was as
you remember when we spoke was to put in
place an enormous amount of support to
help companies to help businesses to
help individuals and their families
through this crisis to help bridge
through it the immediate impact of which
is temporary but then the next stages of
our plan will ensure that we can help
drive the recovery starting with
tomorrow and our shops reopening again
which is a very positive step and then
we need to move on to the hospitality
sectors as well sectors that employ
millions of people and then also help
all of those who have lost their jobs as
a result of this helped them get back
into work
as well so those are all the next stages
of our plan as you were saying high
streets are going to be reopening from
tomorrow a pretty a major part of the
route out of lockdown is it safe to go
shopping and if it is is it almost to
borrow a phrase from that Hancock a
civil duty to go out and start spending
money but it is safe to go and what I
would tell people is I know people are
anxious and obviously we have we haven't
really been doing this for the last few
weeks or months but thanks to the
incredible hard work of everyone in
suppressing the spread of the virus
we've passed our five tests so we're now
able to take this next step on the plan
and reopen retail tomorrow and thanks to
the hard works of retail is up and down
the country who have taken quite
extraordinary steps to make sure that
their shops are safe and welcoming
places for all of us when we go back
protecting their staff protecting all of
us when we go shopping people will
from tomorrow it's a slightly different
experience obviously their social
distancing a new process for returns
there might be one way systems there
will be screens up everywhere staff
available to provide advice and help but
it is a safe environment and we should
all be able to go out knowing that we
should be able to shop in confidence
knowing that it's safe and I know shops
up and down the country are ready to
welcome us all back and get our high
streets springing back to life again and
given the pre dire economic news that
we've seen do you think that it's almost
as if the economy is relying on people
to get out there and start spending
money well I think we've always been an
economy that is driven by consumption
and that that's something that the
numbers would tell you so yes it's
always been important for our economy
it's driven by consumption driven by
services and then the numbers of people
employed in these sectors are huge
whether it's in retail or and
hospitality you know millions and
millions of people work in these sectors
I know they're all itching to get back
to work to the jobs that they love and
when you talked about before you know
the impact that this is having you know
the best way we can protect employment
in this country is to get those bits of
our economy that have been closed reopen
again it won't happen overnight that we
all get back to doing exactly what we
did but it can happen slowly it can
happen in a measured way but most
importantly people need to have the
confidence to know that it's safe to get
out there again and I can give that
assurance that it is and you know I hope
everyone enjoys getting back to their
high streets I mean one thing that would
really help a lot of businesses to
reopen is if the rules on social
distancing were cut from everyone having
to stay two meters away to people having
to stay one meter away
are you considering that yeah the prime
minister has put in place a
comprehensive review of the two meter
rule it's always so we keep everything
under review all the guidance as we
evolved through this crisis to see what
we're able to look at that review will
involve the scientist economists and
others so we can look at it in the round
you're actually right to highlight the
impact it has on business I know that of
course you know it's a difference
between three quarters and maybe a third
of pubs opening for example and so it's
important that we look at it now that we
have made good progress in suppressing
the virus we're at a different stage of
this
than we were at the beginning and that
enables us to take a fresh look at this
obviously you know many other countries
around the world use a different rule
and indeed we've seen a couple of
countries recently I think Norway and
Denmark from memory of moved from two
meters to something less as well but
it's important we look at it
comprehensively in the round and that's
what we will do agent Lee I mean it it
sounds to me like you wanted to happen
well I couldn't I mean I very much
understand the impact the positive
impact it will have on businesses
ability to open and thereby and maintain
the jobs that they have and make sure
all the people that work for them can
come back to those jobs and remain
employed and that's really important to
me but at the same time we must make
sure that it's safe to do so we are
dealing with a virus that has spread
through our country at the same time so
we need to make sure that the science is
suggestive that we're in a place where
if we could make any changes that would
be a safe thing to do a responsible
thing to do so we should look at it all
in the round I wouldn't want to preempt
the findings of it as I said but it's
important now we are where we are in
this that we can take a look at it
that's the right thing to do and I'm
glad that we are okay pretty clear
message there really and one other area
of course that reducing the to muta rule
could make a real difference in is
schools there are reports today that
primary is going to be told that they
can reopen - all year groups if they
keep class sizes 215 pupils I just want
to get this straight you're asking
schools to cut class sizes keep everyone
two metres apart with no extra money no
extra staff and no warning I mean this
is cloud cuckoo-land isn't it
when it comes to schools the first thing
I would say is like obviously every
single day that children are not at
school is a tragedy and I don't say that
because of the impact that has on the
economy because their parents can go to
work I say that as someone who
passionately believes in the power of
Education to provide opportunities for
people that's why I got into politics in
the first place and so that's why this
is important but we ought we are
grappling with a situation where we're
trying to suppress the spread of a virus
we want our children to come back but we
need to make sure that that's going to
not make things worse which is why we've
taken the measured and responsible steps
that we have we had a plan that clearly
set out we would like to bring some
classes back off on June
first that's what we were able to do and
we met that plan we fully intend to
reopen our schools for everybody in
September and in the meantime we have
provided extra support with laptops and
Internet connections who those who
didn't have them we've created a
considerable amount of new online
resources as well and I pay tribute to
all the teachers schools had teachers
who have done a fantastic job in
difficult circumstances to do the best
that they can for their pupils you say
it said you think it's a tragedy and you
say that you know you deeply care about
the inequality that you're worried about
but at the same time you know perhaps
the most important weapon in our arsenal
against inequality is schools and
millions of children and not at school
in the classroom and may not go back to
a September at best you know I mean you
might be okay if you go to a private
school where class sizes are below 15
you might be okay if your parents can
afford to pay for private tuition in
these months where you're not at school
but what about all the other children
are we not risking a lost generation
here well that's why it's very important
that we continue the work that we've
done on suppressing the virus so we can
get our lives back to normal as well and
you're right this is one of the costs of
the lockdown we've talked previously in
the interview about the economic cost of
the lockdown this is an this is another
impact that it has it also has an impact
on people's health both in the short
term with those who are not seeking
treatment right now and those who will
have longer term health conditions as a
result of what happens to them through
the lockdown you know these are all the
complicated issues that we are grappling
with trying to balance balance these
things out I think well it when it comes
to schools there are countries like
Italy and Ireland for example who are
not bringing back any pupils until
September you know other countries like
Spain the vast majority will not come
back until September so yeah I think
where we are is a reasonable and
measured approach but I completely
understand and sympathize that we would
all like to see our children at school
but that's all we've provided all these
other things and we'll keep doing so to
make sure that our kids get the support
they need although at the same time
there's many other countries Denmark
Austria Germany Norway where they have
reopen schools and they haven't seen a
significant rise in infections either it
does make me feel as well there's been
you know Herculean effort to ramp up
capacity in the NHS you've led an
unprecedented economic
intervention and very expensive 1t to
directly pay people's wages why is the
same urgency not been shown to get
children back to school should the
Education Secretary have led a national
mobilization in the same way I think the
education secretary should take
significant action we've created a brand
new online Academy providing I think the
downloads and the interaction with that
have been in the millions together with
other institutions have done the same
but that someone would put in place it's
been very well users have provided a lot
of support to children teachers and
schools up and down the country also
made sure that our most vulnerable
children do have access to online
resources through delivering I think a
hundred thousand laptops and internet
connections to those who didn't have
them something that's wrong to say that
nothing has been done he's very focused
on this issue and he's been working
exceptionally hard as has all of us with
the the teaching unions and with schools
to make sure we've got a plan that is
deliverable has said we delivered on
that plan to bring back especially our
youngest children on the 1st of June as
we said and you did mention some
countries that have moved faster than uh
I acknowledge that but as I said there
are also countries that are moving
slower than us on this issue so I do
think you know we are where we are is
reasonable and sensible and has to be
taken in the round of everything that
we've done as well okay and I just came
to talk about a couple of things that
you've done in your own Treasury support
schemes government gyeom's updated on
Friday which seems to say that after
June the 10th if you're vulnerable and
binds to shield by your GP you can't be
furloughed unless you've been furloughed
before now Citizens Advice estimates
over 70% of those people shielding
haven't previously been furloughed so
these people may have to choose between
following the advice and keeping their
jobs are you going to be addressing this
well I think there's two different
things here I mean the furloughing
scheme which we've put in place was to
protect people's employment which I
think it has done over a million
businesses of benefiting and around 9
million people are having their jobs
protected through this crisis as a
result of that scheme so I think it's
something that has made enormous
difference to people's security you know
when it comes to people who are
shielding we've put in place a
comprehensive set of support for them
especially delivered through local
government to whom I'm very grateful for
in the local government secretary has
worked very high
this to make sure they get the support
and the resources they need whether it's
food deliveries or other community
support to help them through this and
for those from the beginning of this
crisis that have been either isolating
or otherwise have access to our welfare
system when we made changes to that
right at the beginning of this crisis to
ensure that it worked for all those
people because these are essentially our
new situations that we find ourselves in
okay and now I'll be honest I was
actually planning on asking this
question but since we announced you were
coming on the show I've been inundated
with messages on social media from
people who say that they fall through
the cracks
of the schemes that have been put in
place by and the government so people
have recently gone self-employed piyu
freelancers do you accept that there are
potentially millions of people who
aren't getting any support from the
government at this really difficult time
and would you apologize to them I'd say
what Sophie I already did talk directly
to to all of them and I happy to say so
again I know not everyone has been
helped in exactly the way that they
would have wanted through this crisis I
fully acknowledge that and and of course
I'm sorry we weren't able to do that but
those were reasons that those were
decisions that were taken with very
specific reasons you have to remember we
were dealing with something that was
hitting us at incredible speed and with
such severity that there was a premium
on doing things that could help as many
people as possible as quickly as
possible it could actually be delivered
it's no point coming up with lots of
neat ideas but they would have taken
months and months to implement so you
know that's why we did what we did we've
been able to help as I said 9 million
jobs protected through the furloughing
scheme two and a half million people
benefiting from the self-employed scheme
yeah and you know close to a million
businesses benefiting from various
discounted loans business race holidays
cash grants now so I'm proud of all of
that I acknowledge some people will feel
that they didn't quite get what they
want but we've also strengthened our
welfare system considerably as well so
I'm confident that across the piece an
enormous amount of support has been
provided and if we couldn't do it in the
way that you wanted it was because it
would have meant that we couldn't have
done all these other things which were
really important given the situation we
were facing I
okay I mean that does certainly sound
like there's a degree of honesty there
and these the kind of things that you
could look at an emergency budget
perhaps next month well I think at this
point I want to try and look forward
rather look backwards and we've put
these things in place to help bridge
through the crisis and as you as we
started off talking about we're now
looking forward to trying to reopen our
country get our economy going again we
can do that because we've made progress
against the virus we've met all our five
tests so the priority now has got to be
driving that recovery rather than
looking backwards that starts tomorrow
with our shops reopening hopefully when
we get into July then we can get our
pubs our restaurants our hospitality
sector oath and get those millions of
people back to the jobs they love get
give those businesses of proper chance
of actually surviving through this those
are all the things I'm focused on now
then we've got to look forward and we
set out an ambitious agenda at budget as
well about investing in our regions
making sure we drive growth and
productivity through infrastructure
investment I'm keen to get off get on
with that and get back to that so that's
what I'll be looking forward to in the
coming months okay now I am being told
to my ear that we've run out of time I'm
just gonna get one last question in if
that's okay you did a star turn at the
1922 committee of conservative that
benches you've got a pretty strong
social media game whether it's been
pictured in hoodies or drinking
Yorkshire tea you're the bookies
favorite to be the next Conservative
leader you tempted by the top job you
know I I think you saw me I think I've
been in this job for just a week or two
when we saw each other enormous amount
has happened enormous amount has
happened since and it's a great
privilege to have this job you know I'm
very grateful to the Prime Minister for
putting both his confidence and his
trust in me you know especially given
the the crisis that we're facing and I
very much hope I can just keep doing the
job that I've done and keep on to
provide support to people and best I can
so at the moment we're all pulling
together a one team and that's what
we're all focused on collectively
together okay thank you very much
Ritchie scenic the transferor thank you